new information from a deadly Amtrak
derailment in Washington state shows
that the train was speeding when it went
off the rails the National
Transportation Safety Board says a train
was clocked at 80 miles an hour the
speed limit at that section was 30 the
crash killed at least three passengers
dozens more were injured 72 were taken
to hospitals the train was making the
first-ever scheduled trip along a newly
built track south of Tacoma Washington
it derailed at a bridge over interstate
5 in the town of DuPont David beg no is
there tracking the investigation David
good morning Anthony good morning the
FBI is on the scene here in Washington
State but there is nothing as of right
now to suggest that this is going to
turn into a federal criminal
investigation the only glaring red flag
we know about so far is speed the fact
that this train was going 80 where it
should have been going 30 it's cold and
raining right now but the work continues
let me give you a live look as we push
into the scene crews are here and have
been for the last 12 to 18 hours they
brought in two different cranes and
within the last few hours they've been
able to take one of the rail cars that
was actually dangling over the railroad
tracks dangling over the freeway and
level it off ground crews spent all day
and night stabilizing the scene where
the Amtrak passenger train derailed
during morning rush hour plunging rail
cars off of the tracks and onto the
freeway below dispatch calls from the
engineer captured the terror for the 80
passengers and six crew members on board
adrian Thompson says it was his first
time on a train in years now listen I
just feel a whole bunch alike
knocking of the Train and I just grabbed
onto the chair in front of me for dear
life my laptop they're flying follow
them flying and you start to see the the
roof kind of you know keel you're just
like is this never gonna stop and to
stop and when it stopped it was
completely black the train had left
Seattle headed for Portland this was its
first run on a faster new route designed
to shave off about ten minutes the
National Transportation Safety Board
says the train was traveling 80 miles
per hour ahead of the curve over the
interstate where the speed limit drops
to 30 at about 7:30 for local time the
train approached the overpass where one
of the engines and 12 cars derailed it
wasn't easy for the firefighters to get
through there using jaws of life and
different forms of saws to be able to
get into some of the crushed cars to get
access to people and get them out the
NTSB will now try and figure out whether
something other than speed played a role
in the crash is there any indication
there was an object on the tracks prior
to the derailment that remains to be
determined the scene has been preserved
and we will be looking at it very
carefully with all of our rail experts a
local city councilman here in Dupont
Washington actually rode this train on
this route just last Friday it was a
special trip set up for dignitaries
politicians to give them idea to give
them an idea of what that Monday
inaugural route would be the city
councilman says when he came through
this curve this exact curve the train
slowed down there were no problems and
he did not feel like it was going too
fast so what happened here by the way
Gail the conductor of the Train he
survived the crash and he could be
interviewed as early as today David
thank you